[Music]
all of that to come
but we are going to kick off with um
some news that has uh just been reaching
us some staggering pictures we're waking
up to this morning a house that's been
destroyed by a suspected gas explosion
in birmingham let's find out more should
we becky standing by for us hi becky
what happened
well this house has been completely
blown away it was just after 8 30 last
night when people for a few miles around
here heard and felt an enormous
explosion now pictures show a really
quite dramatic scene where the house has
disappeared it was it was replaced
almost instantly by burning rubble of
course a huge emergency response and
we've been hearing stories that
neighbors on this street came out saw
that there was a seriously injured man
in that burning rubble
neighbors actually went in themselves
and dragged him out now we know that
he's currently in hospital
with what paramedics describe as
life-threatening injuries there is some
concern because there was some talk on
this street that there may also have
been a woman in the house at the time we
know at least four other people were
treated here at the scene by
paramedics um serious damage to the
house damage to cars as well and also
damage to surrounding houses now in the
cold light of day i can actually show
you where this house
was standing um you can see
the wall there that's the the
semi-detached house that that was
attached to it there should be a whole
house there just completely demolished
we've seen uh the fire service here this
morning still dampening down what's left
of the rubble there and also workers
here from cadent it's thought that this
was caused by a gas explosion um so
people have been asked to avoid the area
while emergency services continue their
work and of course thoughts with all
those injured here okay thanks becky
thanks a lot cool lucky guy this morning
isn't he um joining us the environment
secretary george eustis hi good morning
see you as always thanks for joining us
on the program start with cost of living
should we last time you were on you were
talking about people buying value brands
from supermarkets in order to try to
make ends meet a little bit easier
this morning hearing from the bank for
international settlements saying that
we're on the tipping point of falling
into a period of runaway inflation
what else can people at home do
well look we've got inflationary
pressures right around the world you
know in the united states the european
union of course here in the uk
as well so the truth is that a lot of
prices are
covered by the gas price and so when gas
prices spike we get a big increase in
fertilizer costs fuel costs and that
goes right through people's household
bills so there's a limit to what we can
do until the gas price comes down but we
have announced a very very big package
of support now 37 billion pounds giving
650 pounds extra to the poorest
households in this country and an extra
300 pounds a year to pensioners as well
to give them a boost to their incomes
we've increased the national living wage
so we've done a lot of measures to try
to help mitigate the impacts of this but
there's no doubt that when you get a
surge in oil and gas prices it is going
to put pressure on household budgets pm
suggested moving away from green fuels
that's uh that's a way forward he is
suggesting to tackle the cost of living
crisis repurposing land currently used
for crop-based biofuels to grow more
food is that something that you support
yes it is something that we are arguing
for at the g7 this week
and that's because if you reduce the
amount of
particularly maize and wheat that is
going into biofuels which is used as
part of the blends in petrol when people
see e10 on those petrol pumps uh that
suggests that up to 10 so the fuel could
be a biofuel coming from those crops if
we could temporarily reduce the amount
of biofuels going into the petrol pumps
that actually does bring back down the
the price of maize in particular quite
significantly washington thinks it's a
terrible idea
well washington and the united states
are heavily invested in
biofuels and they see that therefore as
part of their field security but what
we'll be talking about here is a a
temporary reduction in order to
stabilize world food prices and make
sure that the poorer countries around
the world can get access to the food
that they need so we think it's the
right thing to do but it is the case of
course the united states is a big player
in biofuel so we're going to have to
work to try to get them on board well
they're not going to are they in fact
they're trying to block um any change
that the prime minister might come up
with at g7 well it doesn't um um we
should still argue for the right thing
uh whether or not they they think
they're arguing for the right thing they
well they disagree with it because um
they are thinking as well about their um
their fuel supply and they they see this
as a big part of that and they're
worried about what might happen to fuel
at the fuel pumps we think that's uh we
think that's misplaced we think that
actually you could do this temporarily
it would temporarily increase the amount
of wheat and maize on world markets and
would therefore bring food prices down
so we've done the analysis on this we
think it's the right thing to do they've
obviously got a slightly different view
at the moment but that's why you have
these international dialogues to to
thrash out these differences and discuss
it yeah but you can't persuade somebody
about your point of view if you don't
actually turn up for meetings that
they're organizing the prime minister
didn't go to a meeting that biden was
hosting
well the prime minister is going to be
at um the the meeting this week there's
a meeting happening at
bavaria and then there's a nato meeting
uh later in the week in spain as well um
there's been a lot of international
obviously coming from the commonwealth
heads of government meeting and i'm sure
if the prime minister wasn't there there
would have been somebody else attending
that meeting in his place how are we
going to get the grain out of ukraine
well this is a big challenge there's
there's probably around 25 million tons
of grain possibly more uh that is
currently stranded in stores around
odessa and to put that in context at any
one time we've got about 250 million
tons of wheat in store around the world
and so although it's a small proportion
of the overall total
in the current context it's quite
significant and unless we can get it out
there won't be uh stores for this year's
harvest to go into so we're looking at
what we can do to help to repair uh
railways to look at a you know land
bridge so that we can get that wheat out
across the land border it's now very
very perilous to try to
get ships into the black sea and so
we're ruling out the navy being involved
it's very difficult to do that because
the area is mined and in fact ukraine
themselves uh have have closed their
ports for security reasons and so
there's a whole host of reasons why it's
difficult to get shipping into the black
sea and to take that wheat out of odessa
but we are looking at what we can do to
support them to make sure they can get
it out and the other you know very sad
thing that we're seeing uh is that
russia
it appears are stealing some wheat from
those stores and so what the uk
government is doing is
making available the technology that
we've got to be able to test the
provenance of wheat we're working with
other countries including australia on
this so that we can ensure that stolen
uh ukrainian wheat does not find a route
to market okay how do we do that
you can test the dna of the grain and
we've got samples of ukrainian grain we
did a lot of work on this you might
remember the horse meat scandal about a
decade ago the uk is a world leader
in being able to test the provenance
that's the precise precise region in
which a crop was grown um through uh a
testing of dna and that's what we've
made available we're putting putting on
the table one and a half million pounds
to support that work okay are we
inviting president zielinski to address
um parliament
uh i haven't heard that but obviously
he's addressed uh parliament before so
actually to come along and do that um
well i'm sure that he would he would be
locked too i haven't heard plans for
that obviously that's something that uh
the speaker of the house would would
lead on that uh that type of that's just
the prime minister flying a kite at the
moment then well look he zalenski has
already spoken to um parliament
yeah uh he addressed it virtually i'm
sure that president zielenski uh at the
moment has got quite a lot in his plate
uh dealing with the current situation uh
in ukraine uh but of course i'm sure
that he'd be uh welcome to come and
address our parliament sure that the
speaker of the house would accommodate
that if that were the right thing to do
but it's
very early to be um to be considering
that at the moment but i'm guessing you
are talking to him about how a land
bridge would work to try and get this
grain out we are working with um yes
ukraine on what it would take to ensure
that they can get some of that wheat out
of odessa and into world markets where
it should be
what do we want turkey to do to try and
help with that
well turkey's obviously got a role to
play it's player in the um you know in
the region and in the in the black sea
so yes there are discussions there as
well it's a difficult situation because
a lot of the rail infrastructure has
been damaged through the war it's been
attacked by the russians and it's also
as i said evidence that the russians are
stealing the wheat and uh and actually
um taking it east and we just need to to
make sure that we can try to get that
rail infrastructure back so that we can
expect but you acknowledge that it's a
matter of life and death for some
countries we were in somaliland um last
week showing that unless this grain gets
there then people are literally going to
starve to death well a really important
thing in a situation like this is for
the rest of the world to keep their
markets open and that's why
europe the uk the us are all absolutely
committed to keeping world markets open
because as i said there's around 250
million tons
of wheat in store around the world and
provided world markets remain open we'll
be able to get
wheat to some of those north african
countries that have been traditionally
quite reliant on ukraine but it's very
important that the world doesn't turn in
on itself and put in place export bans
we need those uh international grain
markets to function as intended okay
talk to me about the northern ireland
protocol um the first vote on the
protocol from mps later on today i think
we'll get the result this evening
we had the eu ambassador to the uk um on
sophie's program i think yesterday uh
saying the move is illegal and
unrealistic and talks of a trade war and
retaliation is it really worth it
well the reality is that uh we needed to
do something in this space we've been uh
talking with the european union now for
some time about making the provisions of
the northern ireland protocol work
effectively um the difficulty we've had
is that the european union have said
we're not allowed to change our mandate
member states have said we're not
allowed to have an opinion on this it's
reserved to the european union and
there's been this circular problem with
the european union just refusing to
revisit their mandate and at some point
therefore you have to
take matters into your own hands and to
clarify in law what the northern ireland
protocol means and that's what we're
doing with this bill and it's important
that we do that because we have some
temporary grace periods in place where
we're not
implementing all of the full checks uh
are not requiring export health
certificates and so on and it's crucial
that those remain because you know
ultimately northern ireland is part of
the uk it's part of our internal market
and you can't have a situation where
things like the the sale of sausages
from gb to northern ireland is outlawed
or that seed potatoes from scotland are
not allowed to be sold in northern
ireland it's a nonsense and so we have
to address it what's changed since we
did the deal you know if we start
breaking deals that we've signed sealed
and delivered then why would other
countries want to do a deal with us
well we're not breaking an agreement
we're bringing clarity to how it should
be interpreted and so the northern
ireland protocol always had provisions
for what they call the specialized
committees
to iron out points of detail and to to
to work on those remaining very very
technical issues so whether a seed
potato from scotland can be authorized
to be sold
there's established mechanisms for that
but look this is the problem the um the
european unions refuse to even consider
that or or refer it to their technical
committee so there's no clarity after
the deal's already done you can't do
that no you can because uh it was always
interesting according to the eu they say
that it's illegal unrealistic and it's
going to be a trade war well that's not
correct uh what's legal is what
parliament deems uh legal through um the
legislation that it passes now obviously
we would still uh rather that the eu did
what they ought to have done many months
ago change their mandate sought out
their position talk to their own member
states about what they should be doing
here and then actually come back to the
table and work out how to make that
northern ireland protocol work but in
the absence of that what we will do and
we can absolutely uh you know give them
this guarantee we will protect the
interests of the eu single market in the
way we legislate so we're talking about
having red lanes and green lanes so that
goods destined only for northern ireland
won't need checks but they will stay in
single market which still have those
checks so that gives the european union
all of the reassurance that they need
for their own single money still was
oven ready
it was a complete deal but there were
remaining technical details as i said
over often quite uh banal things like
the the technical way that you uh
regulate uh and allow access for things
like seed potatoes
varieties
these are small things that were
there to be resolved after an eu's not
but do you think that the eu would go
into a trade war over banal detail
uh no i don't i think it would be a very
foolish thing for them to do they
obviously think it's more than banal
detail well i think what they need to to
do is revise their mandates and
re-engage in discussions from a
meaningful basis having talked to their
own member states that's what we would
like them to do in the absence of that
um obviously it falls to the uk
government to german to determine the
correct legal interpretation for
changing the law by changing not
changing though by implementing
an act of parliament that gives us the
ability to derogate from elements of it
where necessary in order to make it work
uh breaking international law is what
the eu say
well we don't accept that because there
are circumstances where
you can actually do this and these are
we're talking here not about uh
derogating from the main principles of
the north island protocol that principle
that there should be no border on the
island of ireland uh that there should
be unfettered trade between gb and
northern ireland and that remains in
place and we will protect the interests
of the european union's own single
market by having those red lanes and
full checks on those goods so they've
nothing to worry about in that regard we
will look after their interest in the
way we legislate through the northern
ireland do you think the prime minister
has the full support of his cabinet at
the moment yes well apart from the one
that resigned last week of course and so
oliver darden has resigned uh and he
responded so he was an outlier and
there's no others well um he resigned
and the the way that collective
government works as you know is that
those who are in the cabinet yes um we
we have our full support we work as a
team uh we have the support of the prime
minister the prime minister has our
support we work together and you know we
stick together through difficult times
and so even when yes you have
very disappointing election results as
we undoubtedly did last thursday we've
got an important agenda that we're
working on and that's what we're all
focused on okay um how do we feel about
our future ken receiving cash in a
suitcase from a qatari sheikh
look i i've seen these uh these reports
you know and i i i i don't have a
particular view on it provided this is
all accounted for properly then
obviously that's something it's
something for the royal family to look
at it's going to be reinvesting it's
going to be reinvestigated by the
charity commission yes and obviously
there will be that investigation and
it's something that for them to look at
but it's not something while an
investigation is going on for me to
comment on well he was previously
chastised by a high court judge um for
calling on the very same shake to
intervene in the development of chelsea
barracks um how wise is it given that
that happened and he was chastised by a
high court judge a decade ago is it to
um accept bags full of cash
look i don't know the details of this
and i'm not i've only seen uh the news
reporting we don't know uh how true that
news reporting was or whether there were
exaggerations they've acknowledged that
they received that whether he physically
took a bag of money and said we don't
know any of that and that's obviously
good well there's obviously an
investigation that the charity
commissioner said they're going to run
let's let that run its course okay just
talk to me before i let you go about um
suggestions by nicola sturgeon friend of
your government of course um suggesting
that if margaret thatcher was still in
power there would have been a second
indie referendum by now
well
i don't think um i don't think that's
right and i don't think we should have a
second referendum now we had a
referendum not long ago just in 2014. it
gave a clear result and i think the the
really important thing is there's bigger
issues that we need to work on we've got
all of these global pressures as we're
coming out of the pandemic uh that's
what we should be focused on and there
it's it's there's too much else going on
in the world at the moment to be having
another referendum okay it's good to
talk to you as always thanks very much
for joining us thank you
quick look at what's happening as far as
the papers are concerned the g7 summit
is across many front pages for you this
morning the eye says leaders are trying
to show unity and international matters
despite their own domestic political
troubles
the guardian reports how boris johnson
urged them not to give any ground to
russia on ukraine
the time says boyce johnson and the
french president emmanuel macron are to
hold her own summit to find more ways of
helping ukraine militarily
and the metro reports on how those
leaders have been mocking vladimir putin
and a picture of putin on a horse from
2009.
well as you've been hearing the prime
minister will use today's session of the
g7 summit in germany to call for urgent
action to help get grain supplies out of
ukraine with countries across the world
suffering from shortages the ukrainian
president will address g7 leaders via
video link urging them to stand firm
against russia in support of ukraine
yesterday russia carried out missile
attacks on kiev for the first time in
three weeks which president zielinski
says is in response to the g7 meeting
what are these missiles about today
what are yesterday's 62 missiles for
only one saturday for 24 hours about
they are about the russian method to
escalate every time international events
take place
siobhan standing by for us in garmisch
in germany for us this morning oh what a
fantastic backdrop um
tell us what the plan is today uh thanks
for joining us siobhan tell us more
morning kate well the star billing today
is going to be president zielinski
addressing those leaders it's going to
happen in around an hour and a half's
time and he's going to ask them to give
him more support to get missile defense
systems more missile defense systems to
try and intercept missiles similar to
the ones that have been attacking
ukraine over the weekend also saying in
his nightly address last night that he
needs
partners not observers so he's going to
be putting more pressure on those
leaders of the world's seven richest
nations to continue that support and we
are hearing that support for europe for
ukraine here is uh unanimous um so that
will be the first thing then later in
the day we're gonna have talks
surrounding climate change energy and
food security and that's where we're
gonna hear boris johnson pushing for
further solutions to try and get grain
out of ukraine via land routes now we
heard from the minister there that they
have continued uh to push
the pressure on this we know that time
is really running out there are 25
million tons of grain sitting in silos
potentially rotting grain that's needed
by the rest of the world and then we've
got in july the new harvest which will
compound the problem so boris johnson
will be calling for more conscientious
work to try and get some of those land
routes open also trying to get turkey to
help get grain out through the black sea
it's interesting though this isn't a new
thing um eu sources were briefing that
they were discussing similar uh
situations as well i think the biggest
challenge for boris johnson will be the
us and canada because boris johnson also
wants food to be put before fuel and
that could be a big problem for the u.s
and biofuels indeed so for now thank you
still to come on the program for you
we'll speak to retired british army
officer general richard barrons as world
leaders meet for the second day of the
g7 summit
as hundreds of british airway staff vote
to strike next month in a row over pay
we'll speak to a member of the gb union
about the possible impact on our
holidays
barristers are to strike this morning
added to the industrial unrest in the
country
the criminal bar association is pushing
for a 25 increase in criminal legal aid
rates
the cba says junior barristers make an
average annual income after expenses of
12 200 pounds in the first three years
of practice
the government is suggesting a 15 pay
increase for barristers meaning a
typical criminal barrister earning
around 7 000 extra per year
a number of firms holding a criminal
legal aid contract has fallen from just
over 1600 to just over a thousand
in the last six years
aisha's standing by for us at the old
bailey so the strike starts at what 10
o'clock this morning
yeah that's right they're planning to
protest here and at crown courts around
england and wells it's going to be more
than 2 000 criminal barristers walking
out over the course of today and
tomorrow and all of this comes down to
disputes over legal aid funding now an
independent review recommended that the
government increase uh legal aid funding
by 15 but barristers are saying that's
not enough and it should be at least 25
to prevent an exodus of criminal
barristers from the criminal justice
system and to give you an example of
staff shortages at the moment over the
last five years more than a quarter of
specialist criminal barristers have left
the profession
so it really does come down to not only
pay but the staff shortages alongside
that as well so these strikes will see
uh barristers uh refusing to take up new
cases barristers refusing return work
which is essentially when they cover for
colleagues who are overrunning in other
cases and it may well prevent uh court
cases from taking place so more
postponements there okay thank you
now bt workers will vote this week over
potential strike action over pay while
115 000 postal workers will also receive
ballot papers dave ward the head of the
communication workers union says the two
companies jointly made two billion
pounds profit last year and he said
enough is enough
and the nhs is to offer faster treatment
to patients who can travel to different
parts of the country part of a plan to
try to eliminate the number of people
who've been waiting for two years or
longer to get treatment here's becky
cottrell
debilitating pain has dominated francis
wakefield's life for years after a car
accident
but now he's in even more agony because
of complications following eye surgery
i don't know which is worse
the x
are the physical pains
i had
cataracts done
a few years back
since having the cataract surgery and
the implants put in the eye
i've suffered with triple vision
and for over the last three years and is
over the last three years
i'm still waiting to go back to have it
corrected
while francis waits his distorted vision
is causing daily migraines it's
excruciating
and there are far too many others with
stories like his
the latest nhs figures showed almost six
and a half million people are waiting
for treatment that's a record and a
massive increase on 4.4 million people
before the pandemic
so to tackle the backlog patients
waiting two years or more can now go to
another part of the country where they
can be treated sooner the cost of travel
and accommodation will be covered but
for francis a long car journey could
mean unbearable pain that would be a
nightmare for me
and i wouldn't be able to just go
straight there and come straight back
i'm sorry
but in the medical community there is
cautious optimism
i think we shouldn't be um too concerned
about patients being offered care out of
area as long as there's provisions for
people say for example who go for knees
and hop hip operations to have follow-up
care locally if needed the nhs says it's
on track to treat all those waiting two
years or more by the end of next month
but they'll need patients willing and
able to travel potentially hundreds of
miles away from home for this plan to
work becky cottrell sky news lancashire
now for the first time in three years
they're accused for wimbledon and
players will play all their matches in
front of pact stands great news isn't it
jackie's there for us hey jackie morning
good morning kay and you're probably
wondering why i'm not in a tent and let
me just explain how it all works so you
know the cures in tents have to pack
them up very very early and they move
them and i'm not joking by about six
o'clock they're all packed away ready to
go and then they move the queue on up
towards the club but i've got a few
stragglers for you and you couldn't be
bothered to camp could you could you
girls but you know you've come you've
come out quite early this morning what
are you hoping to see yes i've come to
see murray and radhikani hopefully get
up onto the hill um
support them from there yeah with a
couple of bottles of alcohol
but you you play a little bit don't you
so you're sort of into it what i mean
what are you looking forward to yeah so
we play a little bit meet up around the
courts of london every now and again um
but i've never been in wimbledon before
but i live quite close by so just
excited to get in the grounds and see
what it's like and on the inside yes
it's a rite of passage shame on you not
coming before and um and you're a bit of
an expert aren't you
but you do know what's going on who have
you come to watch because clearly you're
not going to get onto centre court court
one because you're far too late for that
i know we weren't committed enough i'm
looking forward to um watching peniston
play i think he's done really well and
no one heard of him until queens and he
got semi-finals and i love an underdog
so yeah supporting him and he's caught
three so hopefully we'll be able to get
onto the court and watch him play yeah
and he's super excited i saw him
yesterday we did we actually did a
little feature on him kay and um you
know he cannot believe he's got a wild
card into wimbledon and he is one of the
former grass court players of the entire
season and he's still all quite excited
and thrilled by it all so that is a that
is a really good choice
yeah come on ryan
as with the others just really excited
to get in and see whatever we can
basically and have a few strawberries
and cream because that's literally the
most the only affordable thing on the
menu definitely looking forward to
strawberries and cream which are coming
this year in a recyclable cardboard box
with a strawberry on the front so it's
actually they've gone all out green at
wimbledon this year so um don't need
them too long because they will fall
through the bottom and what have you
come to see i'm not gonna lie i'm mostly
here for the pims these guys they're
gonna do me a quick 101 on rules of
tennis before we go in yeah i'm here for
the day out really
a whole jug of pims well that sounds
like a plan to me a great day on centre
court that is a ticket to have these
guys don't have it but that is djokovic
radakanu and murray but in total nine
brits in action so you're all good girls
you'll find somebody to watch
quit look at the weather for you
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
low pressure continues to dominate our
weather this week which means more
breezy and showery conditions with some
drier and brighter interludes there will
be plenty of showers around this morning
although eastern england and much of
ireland will be brighter and not as
windy as sunday overall it's set to be a
mix of sunny spells and scattered
showers the showers will move eastwards
through the day
the weather sponsored by qatar airworks
looking at some of the images that have
caught our eye in the papers for you
this morning does the pink suit or the
lack of female representation stand out
more in this photo which one is it
president of the european commission
ursula van der lion stands as the only
female in this image in the guardian of
g7 leaders
right at the end as well
pictures from freyja for you this
morning a funny caption here in the
telegraph saying tigger warning these
lucky tourists got to see some bengali
type bengali tigers in action in india
squaring up to each other and you might
have seen this pop in pictures over the
weekend mr happy face is in the times
this morning voted the ugliest dog
in the world i think that's unkind
beauty's in the eye of the beholder
and uh take a look at this in the
express an underwater shot of some
synchronized swimmers
almost looks like a painting doesn't it
amazing
uh coming up we'll be speaking to
general richard barrons the former
commander of joint forces command about
what the g7 leaders could achieve during
their meeting in germany that's come
hello again everybody welcome back to
the breakfast show here on sky news
monday morning the environment secretary
george eustis says that boris johnson
has the full support of the cabinet
following the losses in the two
by-elections last week the party chair
oliver dan resigned saying somebody
needed to take responsibility but mr
eustis said the cabinet is behind the
prime minister
do you think the prime minister has the
full support of his cabinet at the
moment yes
well apart from the one that resigned
last week of course and so oliver darden
has resigned uh and he responded so he
was an outlier and there's no others
well um he resigned and the the way that
collective government works as you know
is that those who are in the cabinet yes
um we have our full support we work as a
team uh we have the support of the prime
minister the prime minister has our
support we work together and you know we
stick together through difficult times
and so even when yes you have uh very
disappointing election results as we
undoubtedly did last thursday we've got
an important agenda that we're working
on and that's what we're all focused on
full support
full support yes certainly the message
from the traveling pms team is that
while it's not great as one downing
street figure put it to me that they
lost two by-elections this is mid-term
they lost a member of the cabinet who
they are saying took responsibility for
those by-elections and the message seems
to be full steam ahead even talking
about the prime minister serving a third
term
some saying oh maybe it was a flippant
remark but he certainly spent some time
discussing the idea of going on and on
and i think some in his party who were
back here in london watching him on the
world stage think that he's out of touch
with the party mood it was only a couple
of weeks ago that the prime minister had
a vote of confidence in his leadership
which he won without a very resounding
win 40 of his mps voting against him and
i think him talking now about um having
a third term when most of his mps have
made clear they don't want him to finish
his first let alone have a second is
only going to
really entrench the the discontent here
we've got a couple of uh international
rounds on the horizon as well we've got
the northern ireland laws that the
government has drafted having their
first vote in parliament today this is
to essentially override the brexit deal
that the government signed and those
trade arrangements in northern ireland
the government say they don't work they
threaten peace and stability in northern
ireland but the eu say if this goes
ahead if this move by the uk government
goes ahead it will be breaking
international law and they may be trade
retaliation so we'll see if any
conservatives take a stand on that today
boris johnson's also got an initiative
at the g7 which the americans are
already opposing uh which is to try and
have less land for sort of green fuels
to try and uh increase the amount to try
and reduce the prices of food on
international markets but sounds like he
may not succeed with that either
i'm intrigued by the third term thing
does he think that this is his second
term as in he did one term already and
then um he he went to the polls quite
quickly or does he really think that
he's going in towards the end of the
2020s so as i understand it um boris
johnson was asked about his longevity a
question that no prime minister can
answer you can never say yes i am going
to carry on forever or you look arrogant
and then as soon as you talk about
leaving as tony blair found in 2007 you
become a lame duck or david cameron when
he talked about it like um blocks of
weetabix twos enough and three's too
many as soon as you talk about your
departure suddenly it becomes almost
inevitable and no one can talk about
anything else so i think to try and head
that off boris johnson said oh i'm
thinking about my third term which would
take us into the early 2030s that
suggests that he thinks this is his
first term now speaking to some of his
team they say look it was a flippant
remark it was a joke because of course
you can never answer that question
someone in his team said it's like the
um you know when did you stop beating
your wife question you know you just
don't you cannot answer it in a
successful way but certainly um a member
of his cabinet brandon lewis when asked
about it yesterday said the prime
minister
has got a long-term agenda and i'm told
that the reason he said it is because he
wants to show that for example leveling
up is which is going to take a very long
time is something he's committed to in
the long term he wants to make sure that
areas of the country that have been left
behind can
start improving and that is going to be
a long-term thing that he's committed to
so the idea he's not going to kind of
run away from office but i think
certainly two mps back here who are
still trying quite actively to get rid
of the prime minister uh it does not
come as a very welcome message okay
tamara finally thanks so much indeed uh
talked about the war in ukraine with the
minister as well it's gonna be top of
the agenda a day two of the g7 meeting
in germany ukraine's president will
address summit leaders urging them to
stand firm against russia speaking to us
now is a retired british army officer
and former commander of the uk's joint
forces command general richard barrons
hello to general thank you for joining
us on the programme this morning what do
you think should be top of the agenda
with the g7 in relation to ukraine
so i think they've got three things
they're going to have to talk about the
the first is the pressing need to get
enough equipment and ammunition
and
support into the east of ukraine to try
and stem this
brutal
but steady russian advance i think the
second thing is to resolve amongst
themselves that we are all and that
means every citizen in the west going to
have to bear our own personal costs for
this war in our own interests and the
third will be to have a conversation
about how to get the grain out of
ukraine to feed several hundred million
of people around the world who are also
victims of this war
uh did put that to the minister he says
it's too dangerous to try to bring it
out via the sea
well it is dangerous and and impossible
to do actually without an agreement that
includes the russians in order to demine
the access to the ports and for
commercial shipping to go in at a
reasonable insurance bill and move the
stuff out but unless something like that
can be broker then then several hundred
million people are going to start
so
in your opinion how do we get it out by
land and what role do you think turkey
should play
so getting out by
by land um is happening but
as a rule of thumb it takes about two
years
to get one year's crop out of ukraine if
you
are using um road and rail so there
really isn't enough an effective
alternative to to the sea and any route
through the sea requires uh the russian
black sea fleet to cooperate or at least
back off it requires turkey to have a
big role in providing secure access
through the boston straits and it
requires commercial companies that are
willing to go and pick the stuff up
seems like the war is very much heading
in um russia's favor at the moment
doesn't it
well i think in the short term that you
know that is so russia will feel it's
sitting on now just a bit less than a
quarter of uh of ukraine it knows that
ukraine does not have their military
capability to to throw them out and it
will sense that there is some weariness
in the world that bearing the
consequences of this war but we should
absolutely recognize russia if it thinks
strategically knows that he will lose
this war it being isolated from the
international community it's a pariah
state its economy will shrink by maybe
15 this year and if ukraine is enabled
to re-equip and re-arm then ukraine will
reverse the military tide
in due course and start to throw the
russians out and and so for russia
probably timing is everything here
how worrying is the growing number of
people joining the um international
legion of foreign fighters
so we should expect that um
many people around the world feel the
need to go and fight for ukraine
if they fight as part of the ukrainian
armed forces
in in a way i suppose similar to the
international brigade in in spain during
the spanish civil war so if they're
formerly part of ukrainian armed forces
then they should be covered by the
geneva convention what isn't going to
work is private venture soldiering
people going to have a go as as
mercenaries or or on their own ticket
that that's not helpful at all
no uh talk to me about uh sivera donetsk
and why
it is important for russia that that
they have now fully claimed that area
it matters because it it's a tangible
victory it's been a long and and slow
and grinding and brutal in many ways
from a russian perspective very
incompetent battle but but they are
going to take this city so they'll use
it as a way marker in the way they try
to say there's the success is coming
coming their way but but the next uh
town just a few miles away on the on the
other side of the river lisa chance is
on higher ground it too will be a stiff
fight so the russians should in no way
think they're going to advance further
into the donbass without paying a really
heavy price in terms of the young people
that they lose and the equipment that
gets destroyed and they'll know that
their capacity to take all of uh the
donbasses
is is going to be limited just because
of the quality of ukrainian resistance
diplomacy always important in war as
well as uh fighting to try to get the
upper hand
um when we're talking about the land
that has already been seized by russia
they could see that as the new
border with ukraine if you like the
ukrainians have said absolutely not and
we will continue until we get all of the
donbasque and the next region back in
our control um there has to be a middle
ground doesn't it
well i think it's it's very hard for um
ukraine to talk about middle ground in
the middle of the war and impossible for
the west to do any
thing frankly but to support the
ukrainian ambition to take their country
back because otherwise how do we know
that if there were say a pause that
russia wouldn't come back for more in
ukraine next year or or try it somewhere
else in the world or even
perhaps just try and nibble away at the
edges of nato the consequences would be
would be enormous we should absolutely
expect russia at some point i would
guess late summer uh autumn this year uh
to announce that it's it's stopped at
least for now uh it will have a whole
referendum in these areas um which of
course will be false to um provide the
political cover for what will be
effectively annexation of parts of
ukraine into the russian federation and
they'll then sit them behind the russian
nuclear umbrella and when that happens
we we will have seen russia
essentially in an act of sheer
imperialism take out about a quarter of
somebody else's country and no one in
the west should think that's in our
interest to put up with it so we'll then
see the conflict settle down not i think
into a stalemate but into a long
grinding conflict with a front line of
about a thousand miles
and in the meantime lobbying bombs at
the capitol for the first time in three
weeks um
one is guessing that that is as a direct
result of the g7 meeting yes it's
happened before so if there's a big
international meeting um russia shows
that it has the
um the weapons that can target anywhere
in ukraine already that's that's not new
and the weapons fired um yesterday were
probably targeting uh
a weapons factory but they were done
from such a long range probably from the
caspian sea that the the weapons were
not accurate enough and they hit a
residential area as well so this is a
sign of russians
reach into ukraine not new but also a
sign of its weakness and it was a very
poorly conducted strike
good to talk to you as always thank you
very much indeed for joining us thank
you
i'm going to be hearing uh from the
prime minister again later on today he
is at the g7 meeting as we said in
germany she born standing by for us for
the very latest on that in the next hour
but before that if you thought wags were
a purely football thing well you might
be wrong um but behind the scenes at the
g7 and a curiously old-fashioned outing
for the partners of the world leaders uh
carrie johnson and the french first lady
bridget macron were among the wives
taking a stroll with walking poles
through the bavarian countryside
accompanied by former professional
skiers
and i'm sure that they go one of them's
carrying a baby as well how cool is that
i'm not sure which um
which lady she is but i'll find out for
the next hour for you cool
now around 700 british airway staff at
heathrow airport have voted for
industrial action next month in a row
over pay and it could mean more summer
travel chaos joining us now is the
national office of the gmb union nadine
horton um hello team ms horton thanks
for joining us on the program this
morning what's the problem what's the
issue
our members are asking for their pay to
be returned to pre-pandemic levels
during the pandemic british airways very
opportunistically used something called
fire and rehire to force our members
into accepting a 10 pay cut and these
are some of the lowest paid workers in
the airline and all they want is to have
that 10 pay cut reinstated they want to
help british airways get back to
pre-pandemic profitability and they
think the best way to do that is to
invest in their staff to ensure that
recruitment and retention is in place
and our members have been experiencing
extremely high levels of verbal and
unfortunately in some cases physical
abuse which has been brought about by
the lack of preparation for the
reopening of the industry and it's
really on the back end of receiving this
abuse and the frustration that they're
experiencing that that they've had
enough and they've they've been asking
nicely now for over a year for british
airways to reinstate this 10 pay cut and
ba just start listening
so tell me more about some of this
physical abuse that your members have
been at the sharp end of
they've had to be escorted out of the
airport by police they've experienced
homophobic abuse
they have been spat out
um i had one woman this wasn't at
heathrow but at birmingham airport where
the ceo has just been awarded a 50 pay
increase
a ticket agent passenger service agent
working for one of the largest ground
handling companies in the country was
pulled over the ticket desk by a male
passenger
out of his frustration and her
colleagues had to have to assist her
so just to clarify in birmingham
somebody dragged one of your members
over the ticket desk
that's unbelievable what happened
well her colleagues thankfully sort of
managed to pull her back and and these
workers they're not on much more than
the minimum wage okay
um and they love working for the
aviation industry they've done it for
many many years they want the industry
to get back on its knees and and they
want to help families to start flying
again but how can they do that when
they're being treated like this
um
given that we know that the government
is against
fire and rehire given what happened with
piano and they stepped in there saying
that it was completely against the
government's uh opinion and position
what's grant shaps doing to support your
union
very little okay um i i don't accept
that this government is against fire and
rehire um hugh merriman was very
outspoken about it during um the british
airways attack on our members
to suggest that the government is
against fire and rehire but to then make
it harder for workers to try to fight
back and and win back what they had
taken from them as a result of firing me
higher during the pandemic doesn't
really stack up for me
um do you acknowledge or to what extent
do you acknowledge that by go if you do
go on if your members do go on strike
they're going to cause absolute chaos
for travellers who just want to get away
on holiday with the kids
the point of a strike is obviously to
organize it at a time when it is going
to be most effective and most disruptive
our members have had to jump through
anti-trade union laws to get to the
point of even being able to hold a
democratic industrial action ballot that
they've that they voted in and our
members don't do this lightly and you
will have heard it been said many times
before the strike is a last resort and
as i said at the start we've been asking
for british airways to reinstate this
pay cut for well over a year now and
where we've ended up is is our members
feeling that they're not being listened
to
and so they've had to take matters into
their own hands and use the power that
they have available to them through a
democratic legal industrial action
ballot and yes it will cause disruptive
disruption and yes my members and i are
genuinely sorry for any disruption that
that is going to cause to hard-working
families who so desperately want to get
away after not being able to fly as a
result of the pandemic but what our
members are doing here is defending
their living standards they just want to
be able to have a decent standard of
living they are primarily women many of
them part-time i've spoken about verbal
and physical abuse that they face
they've got families to look after as
well and this isn't just about them
being able to have a holiday this is
about them being able to put food on the
table
coordinated strike action is something
that's been suggested by the rmt union
is that something that your union would
support
we're not we're not having behind closed
doors
about coordinating industrial action
when industrial action happens it
happens organically
it happens when working people have had
enough and they've decided that they
need to use the power that they have
available to them to withdraw their
labour
if there is an opportunity to coordinate
industrial action and look disputes
don't run on
a linear line you know there's lots of
ups and downs and there's bumps in the
road and there's negotiations to be had
and there's decisions to be had about
when it's the appropriate time to
organize industrial action but if
coordinated industrial action is the
right course of action and that is what
is decided by our reps and our members
because they're the ones that call the
shots in this process we're a democratic
organisation and it's our reps and
members that make these decisions if
that is the right course of action then
i don't see any reason why we wouldn't
so you would support a summer of
discontent
no
it's not about support in a summer of
discontent k it's about working people
having had enough it's about the fact
that the ceo of british airways gets
paid
848 000 pounds and the ceo of iag
the parent company of british airways
gets paid 4.9 million pounds it's about
the fact that british airways paid 1.6
billion pounds in dividends out to
shareholders when it was profitable
prior to the pandemic instead of
reinvesting that money into its staff
and into things like it systems to make
sure that that the airline is able to
function properly it's about the fact
that working people have seen the
sharpest decline in their living
standards in two decades and it's about
the fact that working people have had
enough and actually that they see that
there is some hope in standing together
collectively and organizing and if this
is the spa that lights the flame that
leads to worse you there do forgive me
come back and talk to us um next week or
whenever you'd like to thanks very much
indeed for joining us on the program
this morning thank you